[Musique]
mon rôle ce n'est pas notre le rôle d'un
maire classique
si je suis là pour régler les affaires
compte administratif est exceptionnel
lorsqu'il ya un problème donc au niveau
du son de toulouse fera donc j'évite
donc le ski quelque chose sur ce cheveu
le sien n'est à prendre les
responsabilités
on s'est rencontré lundi dernier donc au
niveau des trois personnes désignées par
effectivement donc préfectures et
sous-préfectures et donc tout ça tourne
bien on s'entend bien encore comprend
bien et moi se partager la tâche lui a
évidemment j'ai signalé au point fait
donc ce poids serait que finalement chez
j'appréhendais est immense elections -
de même dont on constate aujourd'hui où
on voit même que donc comme vous le
savez que finalement non que l'état n'a
pas pris sa disposition finale en ce qui
concerne les élections de juin prévus
pour les départementales et régionales